>>> WHAT IS THAT LADY DOING?
SHE ALMOST PLOWED INTO US.
LUNATIC.
>> OH, MY GOD, DAD, DON'T BE SO
AWKWARD.
>> SHE ALMOST CAUSED AN ACCIDENT
JUST TO SIT THERE IN BUMPER TO
BUMPER TRAFFIC.
HEY!
HELLO?
>> WHAT?
HEY!
>> YOU CUT ME OFF.
>> WHAT?
YOU DRIVE CRAZY.
>> YOU CUT ME OFF.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU DRIVE CRAZY.
EAT -- EAT ME.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
EAT ME.
EAT -- EAT ME.
I HAD MY BLINKER ON.
EAT ME.
>> THAT'S A LIE.
I HAD MY BLINKER ON.
YOU LIE.
>> THAT'S A LIE.
SHAME ON YOU.
YOU LIE.
>> OKAY.
SHAME ON YOU.
EAT -- EAT MY BUTT.
>> OKAY.
THIS, ALL OF THIS.
EAT -- EAT MY BUTT.
>> YOU, YOU ARE A SAD WOMAN.
THIS, ALL OF THIS.
YOU, SAD WOMAN.
>> YOU, YOU ARE A SAD WOMAN.
>> OKAY.
YOU, SAD WOMAN.
WELL, WHY DON'T YOU ROLL DOWN
>> OKAY.
YOUR WINDOW AND SAY THAT TO MY
WELL, WHY DON'T YOU ROLL DOWN
FACE?
YOUR WINDOW AND SAY THAT TO MY
>> WHY DID YOU MIME A CRANK?
FACE?
NO CARS HAVE THOSE WINDOWS.
>> WHY DID YOU MIME A CRANK?
POWER WINDOWS NOW.
NO CARS HAVE THOSE WINDOWS.
DO THIS.
POWER WINDOWS NOW.
BOOM.
DO THIS.
THAT'S GOOD.
BOOM.
>> NO.
NO.
THIS IS TOO SMALL.
IT WOULDN'T READ.
>> I GUESS.
I GUESS.
>> YOU -- YOU ARE SCARED BECAUSE
YOU AREN'T A MAN.
YOU'RE NOT A BIG MAN.
>> SHUT UP.
SHUT UP.
I AM A MAN.
I'M A VERY STRONG MAN!
>> NO, NO.
YOU ARE A LITTLE BITCH.
YOU'RE A LITTLE BITCH.
>> IS SHE -- IS SHE USING YOU
FOR THE WORD BITCH?
>> THAT IS SO MESSED UP.
YOU SUCK.
YOU SUCK!
>> HEY, DON'T -- DON'T DO THAT!
FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T LOVE THAT
YOU USED TWO HANDS.
SECOND OF ALL, JUST DON'T DO IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU KNOW WHAT, BYE.
BYE.
YOU, NOT WORTH MY TIME.
>> BYE.
YOU ARE A GIANT -- THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WHAT WOULD YOUR MOTHER SAY IF
SHE SAW YOU DO THAT?
>> MY MOM TOLD ME TO DO IT.
>> SHAME ON YOU.
THAT WAS RACIST.
>> NO.
DON'T HATE ALL WHITE PEOPLE,
JUST YOU.
>> BRAVO.
BRAVO.
YOU, BAD PERSON.
I FEEL BAD FOR YOUR HUSBAND.
>> NO HUSBAND.
HE WENT BYE BYE.
WE SPLIT UP.
>> OH.
ME TOO.
WIFE LEFT.
BUT IT'S GOOD.
SHE WAS A BITCH.
>> DAD!
>> RESPECT, RESPECT.
HEY, THIS MIGHT BE CRAZY.
BUT ARE YOU HUNGRY?
>> YEAH.
I COULD EAT.
>> DO YOU MAYBE WANT TO EAT THIS
BUTT?
HUH?
EAT THE BUTT.
>> SHAME ON YOU.
SHAME ON YOU.
>> YOU SUCK!
>> STOP DOING THAT!
STOP IT!